[Applause]
[Music]
let me ask you a question do you know
this woman her name is Ursula von der
Leyen and I got to confess that never
heard of her until about a month ago man
there's not just Nene that most other
European know this woman's about to
become the next EU Commission president
[Music]
she would be the equivalent of Donald
Trump in the European Union the most
powerful person in Europe this is
already official well I remember the
first she will take the oath and okay
okay I know what you're thinking
especially those of you who voted in the
European elections I mean here is this
woman where did she come from why her
well I think Eric can give us a bit more
information of course Simon as you know
on May 20 19 your pians went to the
polling stations choose the members of
the European Parliament
[Music]
these are legislative elections for the
EU as a whole and in many ways are
similar to the midterms in the United
States with the parliamentary elections
in the UK so the name of ursula von der
Leyen wasn't on any ballot back then she
was just the defense minister of Germany
Germans knew her but other Europeans not
so much I know you're thinking this
process is completely legal in EU
elections Europeans don't get to choose
the executive power just the legislative
one
so technically anybody could become
president of the Commission as long as
the Parliament accepts him or her in
other words this is totally possible law
wise the politics wise it's kind of a
bit weird
[Music]
just to give an example many people in
the UK complained about Bojo also known
as Boris Johnson becoming the prime
minister but to be fair Johnson is well
known and he was a member of
Parliament's the situation with
Wonderland would be like choosing the
mayor of Liverpool as Prime Minister
just because and yes it's true Vonda
Lyons appointment is a historical event
she will be the first woman to rule over
Europe her name will appear next to
other pioneers like Angela Merkel and
Margaret Thatcher and maybe she'll
become a big historical figure just like
them she might even be a great president
but today's question is can we say the
European Union is a real democracy if
von der Leyen was chosen without being
voted in what's the EU Commission's
president's role well today we are
absolutely going to answer those
questions I mean we always do but before
we do would do what we always do as well
and let's take a look at the history
[Music]
the brussels bubble in the year 1992 the
Maastricht Treaty was signed
we could say that this was the moment
when the European Union with its capital
of Brussels started until that moment
the European single market was only what
the name suggested a market it was just
this big old free trade agreement that
included almost all of western and
southern Europe but it has almost no
political power the European Union was a
giant step because it meant that now all
of those countries would be bonded by a
common governance years later creations
like the euro currency the Schengen area
and many other treaties were all
possible and you might be wondering can
we say that the EU is similar to the
u.s. does it work as a federation as a
confederation well it's hard to say in
fact European institutions are really a
bit hard to understand and usually the
media it doesn't really help with this
you often hear news saying like Brussels
said this or Brussels demands that but
in fact there are three institutions in
Brussels and all three are different
from one another and they all have
different roles
don't worry you can understand it all
very easily with an example that you all
know about because it's been smashed
over your head a dozen times and that's
article 13 but just in case you didn't
know article 13 is the common name for
that EU copyright directive that affects
youtubers a great deal like I say I'm
sure you have absolutely heard about it
many many many many times but this time
let's not focus on what it's said but
instead let's look at how it got passed
it all starts with the European Council
this is the place where the Prime
Minister's of all the EU member
countries come together and say like
alright guys what we're gonna do is
we're gonna need some sort of
legislation to regulate on like
copyright right
they will write some general guidelines
and then they send it to the next dude
the European Commission the Commission
will sort of be the equivalent of the
White House or Downing Street this is
the executive power in Europe they have
a president vice-president and some
commissioners that are similar to a
minister or a Secretary of State these
guys they read the guidelines written by
the council and they write a legislative
proposal which would be the first draft
for legislation once they're finished
with that they send it to the
legislative body which is the European
Parliament this Parliament works in a
very similar fashion to the US Capitol
or the House of Commons but in the UK it
has something unique its members cannot
come up with their own ideas they can
only discuss the proposals sent in by
the Commission for example in the u.s.
occasi Cortes is only a congresswoman
but she can come up with a green new
deal and try to make it pass through
Congress a European MP couldn't this
means that the EU Parliament is much
weaker than a normal one so coming back
to that article 13 thing after the
European Parliament discusses thick they
come up with their own version of the
law but there are still so many details
to polish if you remember the video we
made about article 13 a small detail and
a piece of legislation can change an
entire industry
[Music]
this is well we get the trial ox
trilogue is a process where
representatives from those three
institutions the council the Commission
and the parliaments they meet again and
they discuss the door and finally we
have the final the polished the
discussed legislation the final stage is
when the trial log sends this law back
to the parliaments in this case the MEP
s can vote yes or no but they can't
propose any more amendments
[Music]
so as we said before in this system the
Commission has a loss of power because
they are the only ones who can send a
legislative draft to the parliaments
this is why this is such an important
question who gets to choose the
president of the Commission and this
this is where the big debate starts the
president is chosen by the EU Council
and ratified by the Parliament that is
the Prime Minister's of all the EU
countries get to decide who the
president will be and then the
Parliament votes in favor or against
this leaves the Parliament in a very
weak position because they can only say
yay or nay but again they cannot propose
anybody and this is why five years ago
some politicians proposed the spits and
candid Artin system in this system each
political party running for the
elections must have one candidate for
president
Zelo say if you vote for the Social
Democrats you know that they'll fight
for this specific candidate to be the EU
president sounds pretty fair right well
there is a bit of a problem many
political parties just don't agree with
us let me think about it right now the
council can choose anybody to be
President with this proposed system the
Spitz and candidate thing they can only
choose from a very short list that's
proposed by the parties a few years this
fits and candidate system became a sort
of gentlemen's deal parties followed the
system but it wasn't really written down
anywhere
this is how former EU President
jean-claude ianka was elected in 2014 he
made his a coalition government between
Social Democrats and the People's Party
and now you might be wondering how what
happened during the 2019 elections Simon
well what usually happens with
gentlemen's deals some gentlemen just so
happen to break them in this case these
Social Democrats in the People's Party
didn't have enough seats to make a
government they needed the support of
the Liberals and liberals don't want the
Spitz and Gander Darton system but why
not and why did they end up choosing the
German Defense Minister
well that's have a look shall we but
it's in Candide Otton no mercy in
Brussels they call it the EU top five
jobs the five most powerful political
positions those positions are the
president of the Commission the vice
president who deals with Foreign Affairs
the president of the Parliament
President of the Council and the
President of the European Central Bank
these five guys opened a restaurant that
serves burgers don't know they didn't
they're the ultimate decision makers in
Europe so the question is who gets to
choose them and the answer is again the
council and again the council is made up
of the prime ministers of all of the
member countries then they need the
approval of the parliaments with the
spit sink and a Darton system they would
have a bigger say in this because at
least parties can say the eligible
candidates are so who's in favor of this
well of course is the biggest political
parties what a surprise but who's
against it I'll think about it
[Music]
groans party rejects spits in candidate
process macaron the French president
belongs to the Liberal Party which is in
the third group in other words not a big
deal but as the president of the second
biggest country in Europe he has a
strong position on the council basically
having the second largest economy in the
Union gives you a lot of leverage to
negotiate with the other countries this
is why usually we talk about the French
German axis those two economies usually
all they lead the negotiations so
basically macron has a big incentive to
keep the power of the council as it is
now and Germany being the largest
country in both population and economics
it's pretty happy to so at the end of
the day macron and Merkel they sat down
together and they said hmm no spits and
Gandhi Darton we choose a German
Commission president and a French
president for the European Central Bank
hmm how about that and since Germany and
France have the most leverage on the
council the rest of the countries they
basically just said amen guys amen
you got yeah we have to this is where
Ursula von der Leyen
came into the picture basically she's
the perfect poster child for the
European she's German but she was born
and raised in Belgium she speaks five
languages and has friends everywhere
basically she's the kind of charismatic
person that everyone wants to hang out
with at a cocktail party so as soon as
they introduced her to the members of
the council the council accepted her no
surprise
and I know what you're gonna say you're
gonna say oh come on Simon I can't be it
you see when we tried to make political
analysis here at visual politic we often
try to use things like you know economic
data and surveys and complex strategies
to understand a politician's behavior
but we often forget the politics carried
out by humans like you and like me so
sometimes something as stupid as telling
the right joke to the right person at
the right cocktail party can drive big
political decisions in Europe this kind
of political maneuvering has a name it's
the brussels bubble so who did they
choose for the presidents of the
European Central Bank well in this case
it was a French woman Christine
Lagarde's the former IMF president this
is a great deal for macron he's killing
two birds with one stone but a French
person in power and he makes sure
Lagarde won't run against him smart move
Makran christine lagarde france's dream
president as the rest of the top jobs
went to spain italy and the liberals
let's be honest here the biggest winners
were germany and france david's early an
italian social democrat will become the
next EU parliament president Josip
borrow will become the vice president
and belgium liberal charles michelle
will lead the council so okay the big
question now is what's the next step how
does a celeb underline get to choose the
commissioners well let's have a look
[Music]
from the Lions team according to many
surveys the main reason why Britain's
voted in favor of brexit was not
regulations or immigration but a lack of
citizen control over you Affairs and
after everything we've said we must
admit that that is a bit of truth to
that and you could say oh no the
Parliament still could have rejected von
der Leyen as presidents well look at how
people can change their opinion on the
brussels bubble this is what the
People's Party spits kind of doubt and
Manfred weather said one day Weber urges
you lawmakers to push back against
decisions made in diplomatic backrooms
and look what he said just a month later
[Music]
Germany's Weber urges you lawmakers to
back von der Leyen in top job vote so it
doesn't seem to be a debate at least not
a transparent one that we can see in the
parliament it seems that most of the
decisions are made in a private room in
that Brussels bubble said oh you might
be wondering what what happens next what
can we expect from von der Leyen once
she gets into office the first thing you
have to do is name the commissioners so
we said before the commissioners are the
equivalent of a minister or a secretary
of state in the European Union there
must be 28 of them one for each member
country that means for example that you
couldn't have two Germans or two Italian
commissioners
but of course it's not the same thing
being the commissioner in charge of
Finance a very important spot as being
the one in charge of humanitarian aid I
mean who really gives a [ __ ]
now that nonsense am i right no I'm not
right it will be Vaughn's Ilan's job to
decide who does what so far all we know
is that the new governments of Europe
will have variety between genders there
will be as many female commissioners as
there are male commissioners and this is
where the EU parliament has the biggest
say because right after von der Leyen
names her commissioners they will have
to pass a test at Parliament and yes
those tests are not simple it's common
for some commissioners to not even pass
them for example in 2014 the slovenian
candidate failed at the parliaments
hearings and so they had to choose
another person from the same country so
yes von der Leyen will not have it that
easy in this regard one could see it as
a very effective check and balance
but now the question goes to you do you
think Makran did the right thing by
avoiding the spits on candidates and
system are the Euroskeptics right to
complain about the lack of democracy in
Europe well please leave your answer in
the comment section below also visit our
friends from reconsider media combats
the podcast that provided the vocals in
this episode that were not mine
also we publish brand new videos every
week so subscribe to this channel hit
that Bell button like this video all of
that good stuff and I'll see you next
time and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]